fronteras rusas según la propia Rusia se
expanden tras la luz verde de la duma y
el senado este miércoles el presidente
Vladimir Putin firmó el decreto que
confirma la anexión de la regiones de
donets lugans jerson aunque los combates
siguen en los territorios anexados el
kremlin sostiene que seguirá preguntando
a la población sobre su nuevo estatus
algunos territorios serán recuperados
Seguiremos consultando con la población
de allí que desee vivir junto a Rusia
en el marco de su escalada Putin también
anunció que se modificó el decreto de la
movilización parcial mediante la que
Moscú refuerza con 300.000 reservistas
el frente de batalla una cuestión
polémica al interno de la nación y que
ha generado malestar entre la sociedad
todo ello mientras el gobierno sigue
entrenando y enviando tropas a Ucrania
el Ministerio de defensa ha informado
que no es necesario el reclutamiento
para una serie de categorías de nuestros
ciudadanos como parte del esfuerzo de la
movilización y los enumeró sin embargo
los cambios relevantes al marco legal no
Se realizaron a tiempo entonces hemos
tenido que hacer ajustes a este
documento En consecuencia ya emitió un
decreto hoy y ya se firmó en el terreno
la ofensiva no se detiene mientras el
ejército ruso ataca la región de kiev
con drones y dice repeler los ataques
ucranianos en gerson kiev sigue
justificando sus avances primero el
ejército ucraniano Está realizando un
avance bastante rápido y poderoso
alrededor de nuestro país como parte de
la actual operación de defensa decenas
de asentamientos ya han sido liberados
del falso referendo ruso esto en la
región de gerson pero también hay
avances en la región de harkiv la región
de Luján si la región de Indonesia en
paralelo la Unión Europea aprobó su
octavo paquete de sanciones contra Rusia
Entre ella se debate fijar el precio del
petróleo si la cantidad se fija con los
países del g7 y otras naciones